our second presenter is Patrick fully
and Patricks ties with statistics and
the human connectome I want to start by
giving you a look inside my brain this
is called a connectome and just like
your genome provides a map of your jeans
a connectome apps all the connections
between your neurons in mind we can see
some features that are clearly correct
you have the red bridge in the center
connecting my left and right hemisphere
and we can also see the blue and purple
wires toward the bottom coming out of
the screen those are my optic nerves
that connect to my eyes but there are
some features here that are probably
incorrect for example this green and
white bundle of wires towards the bottom
that's hopefully not biologically real
but is likely due to noise in the MRI
data and in the algorithms used to
produce this connector now these random
effects are actually really important
because surgeons currently use models
like this one in order to plan surgeries
to say cut a blue wire while avoiding a
red wire doctors seeing patients with
traumatic brain injuries also use
connectomes in order to diagnose whether
or not a patient who has seen a wire be
damaged and cut short has that wire we
grow over time now I'm a statistician so
when I think about those diagnoses I'm
concerned about their reliability or
uncertainty if you get any
over-the-counter test you don't just
have a result but you can also look up
the false positive or false negative
rate that way if you see something you
don't like you know whether or not to
spend the time and the money to use a
new test we should be able to provide
similar estimates of error rates for
diagnosis using connectomes
these estimates of error rates would be
easy to produce if we could take a
patient and put them in the scanner over
and over again and observe the
variability and the connectomes we
obtained but since each scan requires
several hours in a very expensive
machine we're using simulations instead
I'm building statistical software that
mimics the random noise in MRI data and
the randomness in the algorithms used to
produce connectomes with enough
simulations I should be able to estimate
the probability that an ordinary
connectome will contain false wires like
the green and white bundle in mine
doctors need to be able to tell their
patients not just that it appears as
though they've had a important wire
regrow in their brain but also how
likely it is that any apparent regrowth
may be due to random noise thank
you